موقف المقاومه في غزه والذي يتواعد
اسرائيل بدفع الثمن
نعم في بيان للغرفه المشتركه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه والذي صدر قبل قليل حمل
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه الكامله
عن الجريمه كما ذكرها الجريمه التي
ارتكبها هذه الليله بحق
المواطنين في قطاع غزه وايضا في حق قيادات
من
سرايا القدس واكد بان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
سيدفع ثمن هذه الجريمه التي اقترفها في
قطاع غزه كما اكد الناطق باسم سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي بان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يتحمل المسؤوليه
كامله وبان
المقاومه تحتفظ بحق الرد على ما اقترفه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من جريمه بحق قيادات
في سرا القدس وايضا بحق مدنيين اثناء
استهدافه
لشقق سكنيه ومبان في قطاع غزه واستهداف
هذه القيادات واسرهم مما ادى الى استشهاد
ثلاثه عشر فلسطينيه منهم ثلاثه من قيادات
سرايا القدس
وبعض من اسرهم وايضا من المدنيين في شقق
مجاوره لهذه الشقق المستهدفه ومن بين
الشهداء اربعه
اطفال واربع نساء وايضا هناك 20 اصابه
منهم ما زال في حالات بين حرجه وخطيره
وبالتالي الموقف ما زال في توتر كبير في
انتظار
وترقب المواطنون هنا في غزه في حاله ترقب
المسيرات التي خرجت
لتشييع الجثامين
بالمقاومه الى المقاومه بالرد على جرائم
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالتالي الشارع
الغزي هنا ينتظر ردود المقاومه المقاومه
منذ ان قامت اسرائيل بعمليه الاغتيال
والقصف واستهداف المدنيين احتفظت بصمت لم
تحدد طريقه الرد لن تعلن عن طريقه الرد
ولا عن موعد الرد وبهذا يكون الترقب هو
سيد الموقف كيف سترد المقاومه كيف ستنتقي
التوقيت وما هو الرد المتوقع عندما يتحدث
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن رد المقاومه
باستهداف مناطق محيطه بقطاع غزه غلاف قطاع
غزه المستوطنات والاراضي المحيطه بقطاع
غزه المقاومه الفلسطينيه لم ترد لم تعلق
ولكن تركت الخيارات مفتوحه وبهذا يبقى
التوتر يتصاعد ويبقى الترقب يتصاعد كيف
سيكون الرد متى
وكيفيه هذا الرد ستحدده والتاكيد المقاومه
وخاصه وان جميع البيانات وجميع التصريحات
التي صدرت عن فصائل المقاومه تقول بان
المقاومه تحتفظ بهذا الحق حق الرد على
جريمه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكن لم تحدد
كما ذكرنا لا التوقيت ولا كيفيه وطبيعه
هذه الرد وبناء على طبيعه هذه الرد قد
يتوسع هذا التصعيد قد تمتد الى مناطق
بعيده او قريبه من قطاع غزه هذا ما سيحدده
الرد المنتظر من قبل فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وكيف بالتالي سيكون رد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على ردود المقاومه
وهل بالفعل لدى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اهداف
اخرى ام كما ذكر بان هذه العمليه انتهت
الى هذا الحد